[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look on what's on the
front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
author christina patterson
and the times and sunday times columnist
matthew science so let's see what's on
some of those
front pages shall we senior public
health leaders from across the uk are
accusing boris johnson of quote
letting covid rip by relaxing legal
restrictions on monday
that's on the front of the observer
britain faces disruption to food
supplies transport networks and industry
as covert 19's third wave intensifies
the times reports
the daily express leads with a prominent
business leader warning that a return to
full freedom in
england has been hit by the government's
confusing guidance over wearing masks
and workers having to isolate after
being pinged by the test
and trace app the telegraph reports that
britain has opted against
mass covert vaccinations for all
children and teenagers with ministers
instead preparing to offer the jabs
just to vulnerable 12 to 15 year olds
and those about to turn
18. the daily star claims almost
55 000 army personnel are yet to have a
first covert jab
and we're joined tonight as i was saying
by christina patterson and matthew side
good evening to you both thank you so
much for joining us
an interesting evening let's kick off
with the observer um
matthew just take us through this
because it's it's a bit
bit of a tricky one for the pm isn't it
with the health secretary testing
positive and
that pcr result just coming in what a
few moments ago
so yeah that's right so it's it's
possible given that sanji
javid uh has had meetings with the prime
minister
and and presumably across uh the cabinet
and
throughout whitehall that it could if
they are asked to self-isolate
as a consequence of this positive test
for the health secretary it could bring
uh the government to something of a
standstill at a critical
juncture uh with the last
opening of restrictions uh due and
imminent
um so that's a very interesting uh
question i mean i i personally think
that
uh in those circumstances although it
would to a certain extent bring the
uh regulations into disrepute if they
weren't obeyed
by the sitting government it is very
very important for the government to
carry on doing what it needs to be doing
i mean for what it's worth i also think
that this pinging one needs to have
i think there's a big problem with it
overall but the wider picture is one of
massive huge uncertainty there are so
many different dimensions to the
decisions that are being made
uh the slight reversal in government
policy that we're we're seeing in terms
of the easing of restrictions the
language is changing dramatically
and i suspect will continue to change as
the number of infection goes up but
anyone who tells you they have a
definitive view
of how the next few weeks will pan out
when the epidemic will peak
and what it might mean for a very
potentially tricky winter
uh i think they'll be certifiable um
christina what do you think it is going
to be interesting according to the
observer the health secretary is
understood to have visited number 10 on
friday
it is going to be interesting if the pm
is self-isolating on the so-called
freedom day
well i i was um i mean i mean nobody
could be pleased that
uh anybody is ill and i and i absolutely
wish somebody said javid well as soon as
possible
but you do sort of have to laugh at the
symbolism
if there is neither health secretary nor
a prime minister
to be present at the press conference
launching so-called freedom day
i mean frankly it sums up the chaos
about as well as anyone could possibly
imagine the point is that this whole
freedom day is a kind of fetishization
of something that is simply not possible
during a pandemic and the reason it's
happening is because of pressure from
tory
back benches and the more libertarian
aspects of the right-wing press
the so-called covert recovery group have
with people like steve baker
and mark harper which has quite a few
members has made it very clear to boris
johnson that they wouldn't
vote for a continuation of any kind of
restrictions
because they are absolutists and
ideologues
and boris johnson doesn't want to rely
on labour support
even though i'm sure he would get it for
continuing restrictions so the net
result of that is that we are now
we have the second highest rate of
infections
in the world even before freedom day
only indonesia and brazil have more
positive cases per day
at the moment and we are literally the
only country in the whole world
who are releasing all legal restrictions
at a time of exponential rise which
certainly makes us
world-beating if we want to present the
new global britain it's not the version
of it that many of us would have chosen
but it's the version of it that we're
getting
and the fact that sajid javid who has
been doubly jabbed
has got covered as a reminder that about
50 percent
depends on which study you look at but
the astrazeneca
jab for example which is certainly what
i've had
two doses well infinitely better than
nothing
and very good at keeping people out of
hospital and
preventing deaths does not stop people
getting covered it has about a 50
55 chance of stopping you developing
active covert symptoms
and it reduces spread by about 50
percent
not necessarily more than that so uh
vaccination is
obviously a brilliant tool in our armory
but it can't be the whole armory
and our government having only offered
it to
two-thirds of the adult population the
job is not done yet
are opening everything and many many
people will pay the price
christina i mean you do talk of case
rates but also
i mean this news this evening that
sergeant jaber has tested positive do
you not think it also
demonstrates that the link between case
rates and hospitalizations has been
broken
and death rates has also been broken and
that's what we should be focusing on no
it's been weakened it hasn't been broken
deaths are going to be rising a lot if
we're looking at
um say we're looking at what is a lot
well i mean the current predictions are
probably a good 20
000 between 10 and 20 between 12 and 20
000 more deaths
in the next few months which is not
nothing but to be honest my biggest
anxiety is about the youngsters who are
going to get long covered at the moment
predictions are that between 10 and 20
percent of people who get covert
developed long covered
many people about 400 000 are still ill
after a year that's an awful thing to
inflict on youngsters i
i was debilitated by an autoimmune
disease in my 20s
thank goodness i got over it but i do
know how debilitating it can be
and it really messed up a big chunk of
my twenties and i wouldn't
i wouldn't impose that on anymore let's
go to the um sunday telegraph
story um matthew what do you think i
just want to prefix it by saying that
the health department has said
that the government will continue to be
guided by the advice of the jcvi
and that no decisions have been made by
ministers on whether people
aged 12 to 17 should be routinely
offered covert 19 vaccines
but what's the sunday telegraph saying
matthew
well well they they are reporting here
on the front page that the
the um joint committee on vaccinations
have recommended that for the time being
uh children will not be offered the
the vaccine unless they're at serious
risk or their
parents or carers or people in the
household have
um immune deficiencies uh
and i guess it will be up to the
ministers to determine whether they
accept this advice
but if this is this is correct it's a
it's a holding policy
uh as i understand it until they gather
more evidence so for the time being
uh that will be the case uh perhaps to
go back to what christina was saying i
i she will know given that we often do
this paper review together
uh that i have been very cautious about
the lifting of restrictions since last
uh march 20 2020 but i do want to just
say that there is a clear risk
in easing restrictions but i'm keen to
know christina's view because i feel
very conflicted about this
that there is also a risk of keeping the
restrictions in place
because it could well mean that at a
time when the nhs is
typically under strain in the winter
there will be another surge of
infections and therefore if we keep the
restrictions now we may not be able to
release them
at all going through uh winter
and i i'll just be keen to understand
christina was very
clear uh if i may ask you i mean i know
i'm meant to be answering questions here
but i'm keen to know your view you don't
think there's also a risk there
christina
that we may never get out of it because
variants will continue to come
we know the beta variant may well make
the astrazeneca
vaccine less effective we know that
there are mutations happening somewhere
in the world
at all times and if we lock down we do
not build up any immunity we will just
be a virgin population
when that uh so i'm just curious to know
that you don't think there's some at
least
alternative risk of of keeping the
restrictions in place
just briefly because you know because we
do have to go to a break soon but please
go ahead
okay um i don't think we should be
opening all restrictions now i suspect
that we'll be reimposing them
come september or october because i
think we're going to see really
exponential
rise i think that you shouldn't open
nightclubs to unvaccinated people during
a pandemic i just don't think it's a
sensible thing to do the easy thing of
keeping mandatory masks on public
transport
would have been such a straightforward
easy win it would have protected many
people
but because of the libertarian back
benches including
boris johnson that's not happening so no
i don't think we should be opening up
now i think there are no perfect
scenarios in the situation it's a
dreadful situation
but i think we shouldn't be going for
world world beating
liberation it's not a thing to be
beating the world on frankly
press preview with me now at the
journalists and author christina
patterson and the times and sunday times
columnist
matthew syed hello again um let's kick
off this time
sunday express the front is talking
about the weather i suppose at least it
means we're not talking about
covert whose story is this
well shall i go first because i mean i
uh i'd have to say
it it's probably too much information
given that we're we're talking about
friends well thank you i appreciate that
we we had a glorious day today i live in
south west london
and i haven't been to gunnersbury park
uh in healing for about 30 years and my
mother's
cousins are all londoners and they
texted me
last night and said they were going to
be in gunnersbury park and i hadn't seen
them for many many years which is partly
my fault because i haven't been to
enough
uh family events it was absolutely
glorious
watching people play football going on
the the lake doing a bit of boating we
played frisbee
i also my um mum's uncle michael who's
93 years old was there with his wife
auntie joan
and we sat and chatted about his war
experiences
uh which i hadn't known about previously
he served on an aircraft carrier
i've got to tell you it's one of the
best days i've had in months if not
years and it just made me realize
i know we've got to be careful with
covered christine i understand that
but we are social animals and that sense
of joy
and um connection that you have when you
socialize with people you care about
it's an absolutely wonderful thing it's
central to what it means to be human
and if there was a prospect for me of
long-term restrictions for years and
years or taking a
bitter off my life expectancy i would
definitely take a bit off my life
expectancy
let's have a look um at that um that
page again the front page of the express
because it is just a great photo
isn't it and at least it says at least
the sun's got us
smiling again so that's that's a nice
little story to start the segment off
with
um christina what is this about robot
wars at ocado
yes well um i'm afraid this one did make
me laugh though obviously it isn't funny
that
uh a warehouse had a terrible fire as
himself but three
robots apparently bumped into each other
and there was that and it and that
caused a fire oh that huge fire
it was a couple of months ago wasn't it
it was is that what it was i didn't
realize it was a couple months ago but
um and i
certainly didn't realize it it was
caused by robots until i saw this this
piece but
um it does show that uh the future uh
the robots and uh are not foolproof they
have their
built-in problems and that certainly
sounds like one of them because one
thing we humans don't do we might infect
each other we don't generally
cause huge fires that go on for hours
and hours and on and demolish buildings
by bumping into each other
so that's one great advantage and one
thing we can cling on to as well as
sunshine at the moment and i have to say
matthew i had
a wonderful day sitting i was had a
butcher review but like sitting in the
garden in my cozzy which i haven't
worn since last summer and it was just
heaven sitting in the sunshine
and um i do think i mean one could
almost forget there was a pandemic when
the sun comes out we're also
pathetically grateful in this country
when the sun comes out it's almost worth
having
the terrible climate the rest of the
year just to enjoy it when it
when it does come out that's when you
know you've had a good couple of hours
when you can forget
the coronavirus i just stand corrected
it was a fire in south east london on
friday at ocarina not that huge one we
saw
um years ago um christina this you're
yours again i'm sorry beth i don't know
if you've
read this one legal action for tech age
discrimination that's on the front of
the telegraph do you both know about
this you want to go matthew
yeah sorry you go ahead christina
now i'm confusing everyone
[Laughter]
quite an important one actually because
it's the equalities
watchdog the new chairman or chairwoman
is saying that it will tackle age
discrimination
as well as other types of discrimination
and i do think that's really important
and the context that's given is about
tech d skilling and
she thinks that middle-aged women might
be particularly at risk
of being forced out of companies through
uh
tech uh you know tech developments and
the fact that they might
we might not be able to cope poor
darlings i very much doubt that tech is
the issue what i do know
is that women middle-aged women are
disproportionately affected
and more made redundant than men
and they do i've got to jump in there
i've got to jump in there we're just
about